okay during the 2016 presidential
campaign Donald Trump campaigned on
pharmaceutical drug prices being too
high and that one of his priorities was
gonna be to negotiate lower prices he
was going to be tough it was gonna be
great for consumers great for patients
great for everybody except the drug
companies and of course that quickly
changed when right after winning the
election Trump met with a bunch of big
pharma executives and lobbyists and he
came out of that meeting and all of a
sudden he wasn't concerned about drug
prices anymore and now he's gone
completely in the other direction saying
that in other countries governments have
negotiated drug prices that are simply
too low and he's calling it the
extortion of big pharma Trump said that
quote it's time to end the global
freeloading once and for all and that
the price controls that other countries
have negotiated with Big Pharma are
quote extortion of quote unreasonably
low prices from drug makers what's the
point of all this why is Trump even
talking about this the reason is Trump
is arguing that if other countries
didn't extort low prices from Big Pharma
the US would have cheaper prices because
we wouldn't be subsidizing the low
prices of other countries and this is
one of the most simplistic and naive
views of drug pricing that I've maybe
ever heard from a president Trump's
basically saying if you allow drug
makers to charge more in other countries
they'd say hey you know what we're
making more in other countries let's
lower prices here in the US since after
all we don't need to make all that money
after all what are we for profit
companies oh yeah we are and this is
ridiculous at its face and experts agree
it's ridiculous as a professor of a
health policy Paul Ginsburg who says the
obvious which is Big Pharma sets prices
to maximize profits right they will
charge the most they can profitably
charge in Europe and then they will
charge the most that they can profitably
charge in the United States if they can
charge more in Europe or Asia or South
America they will and they'll make more
money and they're not going to then
charge less in the United States because
they're making more money in Europe or
Asia or South America and in fact the
market recognized this because when
Trump said this thing which effective
means let's get prices up in other
countries the market thought this was
great and pharmaceutical company stock
prices jumped right if this was really
zero some if as prices went up in Europe
they were to come down in the United
States if that was expected you wouldn't
see the markets so excited over Donald
Trump talking about pushing up big
pharmaceutical prices in other countries
the reason the stocks went up is that
this will be a net gain they'll charge a
lot in the United States and they'll
charge more in other countries and truly
think about how dumb this argument is
right Trump saying that the low prices
in other countries are extortion
pharmaceutical companies aren't forced
to do business in other countries if the
prices in France for example were too
low then any pharmaceutical company
could say we're not going to do business
in France anymore because we're losing
money if they're making enough money in
those other countries to continue doing
business there clearly it's to their
advantage to continue doing business and
this also by the way I was thinking of
the horrible timing of this we just
found out that 1.2 million dollars
flowed from Novartis to Trump's lawyer
Michael Cohen for insights into the
Trump administration not exactly the
best time for Trump to be talking about
bringing drug prices up right when it
when we find out that actually his
personal attorney was receiving all
sorts of money from Novartis for health
care policy work as we learned last week
and when Trump said he was going to
negotiate lower drug prices for
Americans I guess what he meant was
force prices up in other parts of the
world so that Americans won't think
they're getting screwed anymore because
the prices will be really high
everywhere I I genuinely don't know but
that appears to be his idea this guy
said that wages are too high in America
and steel still he got elected you know
this isn't really a surprise now not not
a surprise at all and shocking the con
man isn't really going to lower drug
prices here in the United States